[Musique]
invité de 5 à 10 au matin jean-michel
août aux villes directeur de la mission
locale nord bonjour jean michel lobry
aux auditeurs la mission locale pour
objectif de permettre aux jeunes de
s'insérer ici ça tout à fait en fait la
mission locale sa mission première c'est
d'abord d'accompagner d'informer
d'orienter et d'accompagner des jeunes
de 16 à 25 ans et il accompagner vers
l'emploi puisque la finalité c'est
l'emploi et bien sûr on peut passer par
différentes étapes la formation un
accompagnement sur tout ce qui est
logement santé et autres mais la
finalité vraiment c'est l'emploi la
différence entre le pôle emploi et la
mission locale mission locale c'est un
espèce de pôle emploi jeunes c'est que
nous ne sommes vraiment focalisés sur le
créneau c'est 35 ans et bien sûr
tranches d'âge mais nous travaillons
bien sûr en partenariat avec pôle emploi
puisque nous avons une conviction une
convention de cotraitance et nous
partage en tout cas ce public là puisque
le jeune qui va pas l'emploi et des fois
orientés par pôle emploi vers la mission
locale et vice versa donc nous avons
vraiment ce travail de partenariat sous
le terrain puisqu'elle est une folle au
service pôle emploi et une offre de
service mission locale et c'est pas
toujours les mêmes les mêmes choses que
nous proposons vous travaillez également
partenariat avec le rsm a tout à fait
une travailleuse beaucoup avec le rsma
parce que sa partenaire privilégié c'est
pour nous une voie d'insertion aussi
pour nos jeunes puisque c'est une étape
dans le parcours du jeune aujourd'hui le
jeune bout qui nous voyons qu'il ya des
difficultés que nous n'avons pas
forcément toutes les solutions nous
pouvons envoyer aussi un schéma sur une
table pas en cours avant d'entrer par
exemple dans les formations surtout les
jeunes qui ont des problèmes de
comportement ou certaines petites choses
c'est un petit chose que nous n'avons
pas aigle et bien sûr mais au niveau du
rsma ça fonctionne nous avons bon
partenariat nous avons signé une
convention et cette convention nous la
faisons vivre au quotidien avec nos
jeunes
alors vous recevez 7700 jeunes parents
cela vous arrivait en place et combien
elle à peu près de 2000 jeunes soit en
solutions chaque année mais un simple
prêt à l'emploi est pratiquement entre
400 et 500 jeunes en formation chaque
année formation sur le territoire
formations ont lutté étroit avec la
donne puisque nous avons aussi un
partenariat avec l'ademe pour les jeunes
pousses étaient jeunes puisque certaines
formations n'existe pas ici et
aujourd'hui nous travaillons avec le
jeune sous son projet professionnel
beaucoup de jeunes aujourd'hui sont dans
son orientation subie et non pas une
mutation choisi et lorsqu'on arrive en
insertion lorsqu'on arrive aux missions
locales
on essaie de travailler un projet on se
retrouverait un projet as
là on est sous l'orientation choisie
avec le jeu nous dit voilà ce que
j'aimerais faire et nous derrière nous
devons l'accompagner sur son projet
professionnel et l'aider à réussir son
projet mobile ça passe aussi par une
sorte de remise à niveau du jeûne soit
de la remise à niveau il ya des jeunes
qui sont complètement en décalage et qui
ne veulent pas entendre parler de
l'éducation nationale ou même du
principe même de formation puisque même
si vigasio nationale est un bon modèle
pour bon nombre de jeunes mais a aussi
des jeunes qui ne correspondent pas au
modèle là et pour cela il faut adapter
il faut trouver des solutions il faut
réfléchir il faut les orienter il faut
les écouter et essayer à chaque fois de
trouver la solution pour la personne
puisque nous travaillons sur l'être
humain sur la personne humaine
justement vous savez tout type de public
gv recevait parfois des des personnes
confrontées à d'énormes souffrances
aussi des jeunes que je suis un grand
bien sûr alors c'est vrai que de plus en
plus on a des jeunes grande grande
souffrance je le dis souvent et je le
dis que nous sommes souvent responsables
nous sommes collectivement responsables
de cette situation parce que beaucoup de
jeunes sont en difficulté par rapport
aux familles beaucoup de jeunes sont en
difficulté par rapport à la situation
économique
imaginez des jeunes qu'ils soient jeunes
qui ne travaille pas bien le premier
mois et quand tu m'as dit un jeune
monsieur le premier mois sylvain savant
compromis les vacances mais deux
troisièmes moi à ce moment là ben si on
n'est pas occupé on commence à faire des
bêtises donc c'est vrai que le problème
de l'occupation de ces jeunes là et j'en
mets moins jeunes au centre
pénitentiaire de ducos ont la visite au
centre pénitentiaire il me dit monsieur
quand je veux sortir de là il faut me
trouver quelque chose ailleurs parce que
vous savez j'ai dans un quartier où je
ne peux pas dire non à ceux qui me
disent alors fait des bêtises et ce
jeune on l'a aidé les parties en
métropole et il m'a appelé un jour me
disant monsieur voilà vous souvenez de
moi je dis oui je ne peux pas oublier
effectivement je me souvenais de lui il
me dit bon voilà je me suis marié j'ai
une femme j'ai un enfant
et voilà j'ai construit ma vie là-bas et
c'est vraiment grâce à vous grâce à la
mission locale
et là on a quelques exemples comme ça de
réussite malgré le fait qu'on soit bien
qu'aujourd'hui on ne peut plus pas
trouvé la solution pour tous les jeunes
mais on a des jeunes qui ont voulu
arrive à s'en sortir du concept
en fait cette expérience montre que les
jeunes malgré leur bêtise ou bien
quelques bêtises des jeunes sont
récupérables à les jeunes sont
complètement intolérables il faut se
dire une chose des chercheurs ont prouvé
que la partie du cerveau qui s'occupe du
comportement est qui qui amène le
comportement une certaine maturité cette
partie du cerveau qui arrive à maturité
à partir de 22 23 24 ans cette période
là effectivement c'est bien que un jeune
de 16 ans 17 ans 18 ans b ces jeunes-là
dysfonctionne après c'est comme on
accompagne les familles pour que ce
moment douloureux soit abordée de la
manière la plus simple possible et puis
qu'on puisse aider le jeune et les
familles à trouver les solutions
je sue interpellé par des mamans qui me
disent le jeune je n'en peux plus je
n'en veux plus jeune maître de junon
nommé trader parce que vous allez aussi
est en souffrance
alors je comprends la souffrance d'avant
un enfant à la maison qui injurie la
famille ou les choses comme ça mais je
crois qu'aujourd'hui nos jeunes méritent
un accompagnement mérite des solutions
peut-être que c'est anne aussi le
construire les choses avec eux en tout
cas la mission locale on multiplie les
actions pour essayer d'occuper les
jeunes et de construire quelque chose de
2,1 climat favorable que eux s'en
sortent et qu'ils passent ce cap
difficile et qu'ils arrivent à se
construire
la mission locale nord ne reçoit pas que
des jeunes du nord d'ailleurs je ne suis
légalement je sais des missions locales
sur sur toute la martinique
alors c'est vrai qu'un humain dans cette
transaction spécifiques et là les jeunes
viennent le voir je ne peux pas dire à
un jeune on a on a une action sur les
emprunts saisonniers en montagne on
amène des jeunes chaque année depuis
onze ans qu'on en parle et parle pas là
quelques actions comme ça où les jeunes
nous était appel
et là il est difficile de dire non à un
jeune qui vient vouloir alors
accompagner les jeunes donc à la
création d'entreprise peuvent via un
dispositif de parrainage n'avait alors
rien dispositif de parrainage vers
l'emploi mais on a aussi un dispositif
de parrainage vers la création de risque
que chaque année nous accompagnons entre
40 et 50 jeunes sous le volet fonds
création d'entreprise est à peu près
entre 12 et 20 jeunes créé leur activité
et c'est vraiment un service qui est
gratuit pense que nous ne faisons rien
payé à la mission locale tout est
gratuit
le jeune vient il a une idée à partir
d'une idée il ya un conseiller en
création d'entreprise qu'il a à sa
disposition et qu'il l'aide à monter son
projet
à mener le projet jusqu'à maturité à
trouver un local les premiers conseils
les premiers problèmes et trouver les
financements et les financements bien
sûr nous montons les dossiers avec les
jeunes pour le financement au niveau
depuis sa création au niveau du prêt
d'honneur avec l'initiative martinique
on a aussi au niveau de la ctm nous
avons le faux nez de microprojets tout
toutes ces aides a en tout cas nous les
maîtrisons et ne travaille avec le jeune
pour que le projet réussisse vraiment
c'est le projet du jeune et nous
travaillons avec le poussa et les
parents qui viennent derrière sur les
par un chef d'entreprise qui vont donner
les premiers conseils pour dieu ne fait
pas si moi j'ai fait ça ou où j'ai pas
fais il fait ça et c'est vrai que c'est
très très content de leur expérience
dans leur expérience et c'est vrai que
moi j'étais jeune créateur à 24 ans j'ai
créé mon entreprise et je sais ce que
c'est que le parcours du combattant
et c'est dans ce sens que j'ai voulu
aider les jeunes martiniquais ressenti
la semaine dernière vous avez remis des
diplômes à ans neuf jeunes qui ont tout
à fait suivi au canada une formation au
management et de leadership qu'est ce
que c'est alors c'est vrai que lorsque
nous manions les jeunes nous voyons bien
que ces jeunes-là ya une petite limite
celle que nous voulons construire les
vrais leaders de domaine nous avons des
jeunes créateurs d'entreprise mais nous
voulons faire des leaders phallique des
jeunes qui sont en capacité de commercer
avec l'international de travailler avec
les états unis le canada et ainsi de
suite et nous avons eu l'idée de mettre
en place cette formation - de participer
à cette formation qui existe déjà depuis
les années au canada avec l'institut du
leadership et l'université de concordia
pour faire monter le niveau de ces
jeunes là nous avons eu neuf jeunes
c'est vrai que les moyens ne sont pas
énormes donc nous pouvons amener tous
les jeunes mais nous avons sélectionné
neuf jeunes que nous avons menées sur le
canada pour cette formation est née au
chip et c'est une formation très
intéressante parce que sur une semaine
les jeunes ont eu pratiquement une
vingtaine d'intervenants et le niveau
était très élevé mais vraiment très très
bon niveau et ils étaient en groupe avec
d'autres personnalités on avait des
douzaines de personnes de l'afrique
nous avons notamment le directeur du
développement de la de la démocratique
de congo dit que le cursus de ces jeunes
alors la formation ce qui a été demandé
c'est que le jeune soit comme un chef
d'entreprise est ancré sur l'activité
ayant déjà au moins
la nuit ou voilà avec des connaissances
d'or dans l'entreprise parce qu'il y
avait des formations où il fallait que
le niveau soit un petit peu élevé mais
y'avait pas de conditions de diplômes
parce que le canadien ne fonctionne pas
un peu comme nous là bas c'est tout est
basé sur la motivation sur l'envi et pas
forcément sur les diplômes et cette
formation de haut niveau a été suivie
par les jeunes ça s'est très bien passé
les jeunes ont rendu un mémoire et 5 de
neuf jeunes ont reçu leur diplôme la
semaine dernière parce qu'ils sont allés
jusqu'au bout ils ont démontré des
capacités et j'espère que ces jeunes
deviendront de super leader et qu'ils
embauchent fera le maximum de personnes
d'accord ce seront des futurs chefs
d'entreprise alors ce soir des chefs
d'entreprises déjà mais j'espère que ce
sont des futurs grands leaders mais ils
sont déjà chef d'entreprise d'accord
alors vous menez également chaque année
une action pour les jeunes qui sont dans
le secteur de la restauration et de
l'hôtellerie si ça ça s'appelle l'emploi
saisonnier tout à fait on s'est rendu
compte que en martinique on se plaignait
tout le temps de ne pas être en capacité
d'accueillir les touristes
convenablement de ne pas avoir le bon
niveau de service et je me suis dit
qu'il fallait un moment donné qu'on
contrarie un petit peu cela et on a eu
l'idée en 2007 de faire partir des
jeunes pour la première fois sur la
métropole sur les emplois saisonniers
pascali région comme la savoie savoir
savoir où nous en coûte des personnes
mais ils ont pas assez de jeunes le
territoire l'idée c'était pas d'envoyer
nos jeunes en concurrence avec d'autres
jeunes c'est d'envoyer des jeunes sont
un territoire il ya une pénurie pénurie
de main d'oeuvre dans les secteurs
l'hôtellerie restauration en montagne en
montagne tout à fait non c'est vrai que
c'est assez particulier au début ils ont
commencé à se moquer de nous deux jeunes
martiniquais qui arrive à la neige bon
c'est particulier sauf que nos jeunes
ont démontré qu'ils avaient les
capacités gaver les compétences
aujourd'hui nous avons pas cher
cuisinier en montagne vraiment je suis
très fier de ces jeunes là nous avons
deux jeunes cuisiniers chez babette de
rozières nous avons un jeune sous le
fouquet's sur les champs-elysées
moi j'ai on a visité des jeunes un jeune
qui s'appelle jérémy de lyon qui est au
mercure de la rochelle on a visité tous
ces jeunes là qui nous donne vraiment
des raisons d'espérer pialat qui
reviennent et qui servent le pays
moi j'ai en mémoire un jeune qui
s'appelle pascal joly sans autres
familles qui
pascal sujet voilà qui est aujourd'hui
aussi mon équipe à ces chefs de parti
qui est parti à monaco avec le chef
marcel ravin et ce jeune a vraiment une
bonne expérience sur les emplois
saisonniers et au voulu peut faire
valoir sa dans l'hôtel le simon en
martinique et on espère que beaucoup de
jeunes vont revenir apporter leurs
compétences à l'eau territoire d'origine
le gouvernement qui prévoit et ce sera
ma dernière question qui prévoit une
réforme de la formation professionnelle
je pense que vous avez déjà lu un peu ce
qu'il y avait dans cette saison qu'est
ce qui vous attire où il ya des choses à
remanier dans cette réforme
alors c'est vrai qu'aujourd'hui nous
sommes interpellés par le préfet qui
font un gros travail
franck robine pour que les assises de
l'outre-mer se passe correctement et
qu'on apporte un maximum d'idées moi
j'ai participé à différents ateliers et
on est en train de mener la réflexion en
fait on est dans une espèce de co
construction
aujourd'hui le gouvernement dit nous
avons des choses les choses ne
fonctionnent peut-être pas forcément
correctement et qu'est-ce que vous
professionnel vous avez à dire ces
choses là qu'est ce que vous avez vous a
apporté
moi j'apporte ma pierre ma pierre à
l'édifice on a vu que par exemple sur le
contrat d'apprentissage y avait des
choses qui ne fonctionnait pas il faut
écouter légèrement reprise il faut
écouter les jeunes il faut écouter aussi
les centres de l'ailé cfa pour trouver
les meilleures solutions je disais c'est
vrai que je vous donne un contrat un
contrat de l'apprentissage qui ont
contraint travail peut-être que demain
il faudra transformer en contrat de
formation parce que les jeunes ont du
mal à trouver les entreprises en tout
cas la première année donc il ya des
réflexions à mener et surtout cela
formulées sur l'adaptation au marché du
travail
jean michel tobie jose remercie
excellente journée alex dunn au
programme aussi merci beaucoup à partir
des premières mesures éditeurs
[Musique]